hallelujah hallelujah
can i can i just like i cannot
control my hangovers or my alcohol
intake because
if i have one drink i wake up feeling
like [ __ ] and i promise you this is not
even
a joke and i have not found a way to
actually
cure these hangovers i've done coconut
water i've done eating a ton of bread
before i go to bed
advil and so cbd talks came to my door
and they're like please just try it out
and i was like
all right sure like there's this is
maybe gonna work i don't know
you guys i've already run out of one box
it works no it actually it actually
works both times that i've used it i've
woken up completely fine i'm on
the treadmill at 8am let me explain a
little bit about what
cbd talks is it is a cbd-based hangover
remedy
that targets the physical and mental
aspects of hang out because those mental
aspects man
i'm foggy it's a natural compound found
in hemp that can help you feel
calmer alleviate pain and nausea helps
your body get rid of toxins i mean it's
like
it's like a sauna without having to
sweat this is like the holy grail yeah
each dose of cbd talks contains
40 milligrams of pure premium cbd
extract from hemp
plus a range of all other natural
antioxidants electrolytes vitamins
detox agents to help you feel better and
to help your body recover faster
it contains zero percent i'll say that
one more time
zero percent thc so it doesn't make you
feel
high it definitely did no it definitely
didn't all right
i'm going to tell you guys called action
because not only did they send these
they sent us a bottle of cos amigos so
you know that they're a great company
we have a special 20 off discount for
you so go to
shop.getcbdtalks.com shop.getcbdtalks
that is c b d t o
x dot com and use the code on wax at
checkout
they offer a 30 day money back guarantee
so you have nothing to lose when you're
trying it out
again so go to shop.getcbdtalks.com and
use the code
unwaxed for 20 off you can also find
them on instagram at
cbdtalks remedy let us know what you
think because
we definitely did and we love it what
the [ __ ] is going on
i like to party jesus honey
from podcast one this is unwaxed get in
loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends yup
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to another
episode of
unlaxed we were synchronized there i
know that was pretty good
getting fancier with these intros no
sistine are a little tired
this morning yeah we have our energy
drinks i don't know can you pop it open
yeah let's do it
asmr actually that sounded really nice
cheers oh my god yeah um we had a long
night last night
definitely it was a little slow this
morning we've kind of been doing
um sober quarantine a little bit we
really haven't been drinking that much
just someone like us i know and our
tolerance though has just been
yeah so we had one drink last night and
yeah
i feel like i got hit by a bus yeah like
you put your alarm on this morning
because you were like i need to or last
night just because you thought you were
sleeping
yes does anyone else get this where they
have a weird
guilty conscience after they drink like
i feel
guilty for drinking therefore spending
the day in bed the next morning
yeah like i my body won't allow it my
body
reacts now you know the sunday scaries
happens to me every single week whenever
i drink it's not just
that like my body needed rest in the
6 30 a.m no no you can't get up now i've
never woke up but then i
i think about the things i did last
night when i know i didn't do anything
wrong last night did i say something
stupid did i do something stupid
well i can tell you you didn't do
anything stupid thank you i think i did
pretty good
i didn't really say much we've actually
um
we're gonna take it down or not yeah so
it was actually interesting so the whole
point of our show we call it unwaxed
and yes we are naturally we love to be
goofy
we like to talk about zany topics and
we're on wax and we're unlocked
but that also means that we are deep
we're gonna be raw and real with you
guys and i think that it'd be
interesting to open up the show with
a different topic that we actually had
talked about this week
and i think it's important to talk about
because i don't think a lot of people
think about this i mean people talk
about this topic we're gonna
but not openly but not open yeah so
we kind of had a big realization well i
want to say you had a big relationship
sophia is a very deep thinker
and i don't like to think about my
feelings and she
sort of yanked it out of me so we're
gonna
i think it's good to self reflect so i
was thinking about basically
what has happened to me during
quarantine i was thinking about
the changes in my life what we've been
doing every day
and what's been positive what's been
negative and
we are thinking about what is really
been the
foundation and solid nice niceness for
us
nice it's not the word comforting yeah
thing for us during the pandemic
silver lining yeah and i mean everyone's
going through something
hard right now it's really chaotic i
mean everything's been progressive but
some things are digressing and
um we have a pandemic we're dealing with
california fires everywhere i mean
there's riots this there's a hostile
election
it feels very unbalanced and foreign
state for us to be in
and and everyone's just anxious and
scared and nervous
and no one really knows what's going to
happen in
the next month two months or a year yeah
and i was thinking about
everything before and i was like before
the pandemic before the elections before
everything
what was my main priority and i was
really putting and i still
i still put pressure i think you are
like this too on
working and being successful and making
sure like i make money
and i i have this career for myself i
was not focusing really on
anything else and i believe that my
happiness
would depend on my profession or who i
saw myself in life and where i put
myself
and definitely put so much pressure on
yourself i mean i think i do too but
internally
i think that we have this um and no one
puts this pressure on us our parents no
really
but i think it's just the stress of okay
they had their careers figured out
pretty early on we're in our early 20s
school is over
you should have your career figured out
by now you should be making x amount of
dollars
and then on top of that you should have
this thriving social life you should
have this thriving like relationship
personal life and like you want to be a
good daughter i mean etc etc yeah and
since the world though has been kind of
turned upside down
for good and bad reasons um we realized
that
there's really one thing that has been
the x factor of making this whole
situation better
and i realized that it really is love
warmth and a family yeah and
i believe that with everything that goes
on in life
beauty fades if you work on your
physique you always should be healthy
but
beauty fades money can be taken away
from you in a second the world you can
see
can be switched like this without even a
second thought
and the only thing that i felt has been
my saving grace has been having my
family around me
yeah and i go okay wow so take a step
back
my priorities in before were really
about in special i was not even thinking
about
marriage at all i was not even thinking
i was like i want to freeze my eggs
maybe get married at 35
like i really want to just work work
work work make a lot of money
and i go that's really not that
i feel like fulfilling and because at
the end of the day i'm going to come
home and all i want now
when i come home to my walls is i want
to have a kind husband
and good kids and i want you around and
my family around and
i like to define family as whatever you
define it as it doesn't have to be
a husband or your partner it can be a
group of friends or one best friend
it can be your sisters it can be that
your yeah whoever it is there really is
such a loose definition of family but
i think nurturing those whatever state
you're in because you could go
from being at the top of your game to
completely falling crashing and the only
people that are going to be around you
is that family and love and warmth and
i decided i was like you know what i'm
not i'm going to keep working hard i'm
going to keep working that's something
that is very passionate for both of us
but i'm not going to put so much
pressure on that
and i'm really going to start figuring
out how i'm going to build
i mean i guess my own family in the
future because you can't control
yeah people around you the world around
your environment around you
you can control what goes on inside your
own walls yeah so
what do you think
you want to prioritize more now like for
you
sophia is such a five-year 10-year kind
of person i am i'm like
i don't even know what tomorrow brings
for me yeah so
for you what are you hoping to gain so
i'm hoping out of this that i think
something that everyone should take note
on is
to buy experiences and not things
after this whole pandemic i really i
just remember that by experiences and
not things
when we go out to a concert or when we
go out to a trip
do you remember that way more than a
shirt you bought or
that thing you were just dying to have
that materialistic items can fade really
easily so that's something i want to do
is make more memories travel
i really want to keep nurturing the
friends around me because those are my
people that have been the only things
that have made me feel better during
this i feel like you've been better at
reaching out to people yeah and i've
been really reaching out to the people
that are
really super important in my life that i
feel like are going to be those people
that
are going to be around me regardless of
what happens and that are going to be
comforting
but the also another part of this whole
thing that
the reason why this all came up was i
took a class at usc
and this man came in and he is very
philosophical and he talked about how
he spent time working in hospice and he
would be with these people that were
basically on their last legs
and repeat to us the five things that
they said
on their almost their last words and it
was really sad and i wrote them down
because i found them in my notebook and
i remember at that moment when i took
the class
it was really impactful for me yeah so
there's five things that these people
said
one i wish i traveled more
two i wish i hadn't worked so hard
and then i think that's something that's
big for us is that we always are trying
to work
and we love to work but i mean you time
flies so fast when you're not really
thinking about the moments day to day
when you're just thinking 10 years ahead
and that's my problem
three i wish i lived a life true for
myself and not what others expected
right and i feel like we can all get
caught up in what people
think about us and what we're supposed
to be doing i mean we please though to
please them and
okay we're supposed to get the nine to
five and then we're supposed to get that
finance job and then we're supposed to
go do this
and at the end of the day you come home
you're like my passion is music
and then you just wasted your entire
life not really pursuing the thing that
makes you happy
three i mean four i wish i let myself be
happier
and not be so angry yeah it's really
easy to get frustrated it's actually i
feel like it's almost sometimes harder
to be happy
with things versus the angry things
right i i mean i get really frustrated
things easily sometimes
i think especially now it's yeah like
the little things
i feel um like my my mood swings have
been
sort of all over the place one day i
feel like i'm being suffocated and i'm
drowning
with my own like emotions and the next
i'm trying to wake up happy so
especially in quarantine it's like
mental health you really
need to check in on yourself and and
write down your thoughts and reach out
to your friends
and do the things that make you happy be
around the people that make you happy
absolutely that's the only thing
why live a life when that is so short
for us
when and spend it with people that are
negative toxic
or you surround yourself in a toxic
environment and so
the fifth one was i wish i fell in love
and was loved
all right hold up on the fifth one
mm-hmm
sink that in i think i found love fifth
one be loved
i think the fifth one is um especially
prevalent to us right now
maybe you a little bit more because we
have been
you know dating and this and that and i
remember sophia brought up to me the
other night and she's like okay like
i've been going out with people i sort
of feel like i know what i want
and what do you want
in the beginning what i thought i wanted
when i wasn't really taking a step back
was someone that was almost like as much
of a
go-getter with everything as me like
because my emotions i go
i'm on like a high-end i have any high
anxiety or i'm like very chill or i'm
kind of all over the place and i was
thinking that would be fun to have
someone like that but then i'm
thinking about what's been happening in
the last couple months and i go
you know i want someone around me that
is going to be my rock
that's it i want someone that is going
to be my best friend
that is going to be my comfort my home
well you go get them so
what about you i mean what what have you
thought about have you because i know we
talked about this but
you guys i'm just a cold-hearted person
no one has
been able to melt my ice heart someone
will
will find that person so i am really
happy we got to bring this up because
i think that we all need a little bit of
a reminder that
it's important to take a step back and
really prioritize the things that are
important in your life and what will
make you happy
buy experiences not things surround
yourself with your own family and
fall in love don't fall in love i mean
travel more
experience life don't work so hard i
mean work hard at the things that you're
passionate about
so everyone get out there be on wax be
yourself
we are really excited to have on dr
katz yes you guys we have a plastic
surgeon coming on
for this episode and i feel like living
in la
it's basically everywhere oh and i'm so
excited to sort of dive in ask her
questions
she's a specialist in body contouring
well
vaginal rejuvenation and tummy tuck is
what her specialties are apparently
ouch woof i'm excited we have a lot of
questions so
stay tuned everyone listening check
check
testing mic check i heard um
there's this new cool little trendy
thing for all those little
aspiring chefs out there yeah it's
called green chef
y'all heard of it well now you will
green chef is a usda certified organic
company
and the meal plans listen include paleo
plant-powered
keto and balanced living you guys it
makes eating
affordable easy and your meal plans fit
into everyday lifestyle
and if you're worried that you don't
know how to cook and you're just like
i don't have the tools i don't have the
photos i don't have the ingredients
now you do they give easy step
step-by-step instructions chef tips
photos to go along with every step of
the way and
it comes hand-picked and delivered right
to your door
sophie and i are so freaking excited
to get our green chef delivered to our
door and because times are still a
little bit crazy
they're offering contactless delivery to
our doorstep
for easy home cooking use code unwaxed
80 to get 80
off your first month plus free shipping
on your first box
go to green chef dot com slash unwaxed80
to redeem and for more details susteam
yes
do you know all the things we love to do
for ourselves we haven't done it yet for
some reason
okay we've always wanted straighter
teeth and a better smile so stop putting
it off
thanks to candid straightening your
teeth are simpler easier and more
comfortable than ever yeah candid clear
aligners are comfortable removable
and practically invisible unlike those
nasty
wire braces which we had to do for about
six years thank you
so transform your smile without anyone
noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who is an experienced
expert in tooth movement i've never even
heard of that so they must be
bomb at that and it's all done from the
comfort and convenience of your home
yeah they only work with orthodontists
you know we got the og tooth experts
on this case never general dentist like
other companies plus
your supervising orthodontist will be
with you every step of the way
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring
by the same orthodontist who created
your plan so you never have to wonder
how you're doing you'll always know and
i
personally love that the average candid
treatment is just six months you'll
start seeing results
way before then and it costs thousands
less than braces so listen up people
start straightening your teeth today
right now all of my listeners can save
five dollars on candid starter kit go to
candidco.com
unwaxed and use code unwaxed that's
candidco.com
unwaxed code unwaxed take advantage of
this limited time offer to save
75 dollars baby on your starter cake
candid co.com
unwaxed code unwaxed
this badass double board certified
surgeon who although is well-versed in
all areas of plastic surgery
is known for his signature natural
looking tummy tuck and is for being a
pioneer in the vaginal cosmetic surgery
and rejuvenation
this lady destroys all stereotypes and
paves the way for all women to truly be
themselves
this is dr catherine begnavik how do you
pronounce your last name
you got it i was gonna ask you before i
should have probably done that but
you oh my god no worries i go by dr cat
anyway doctor cat perfect
i'm not even joking like when we heard
that we were gonna have you on
and you even like were offering we
freaked out we freaked out and then you
walk in the door looking
so glamorous and stunning oh you're
the way for like women and who do
cosmetic procedures like
they it's it's male dominated as i
yeah very right i mean i think that when
i came into private practice
less than 10 of board certified plastic
surgeons are women so like think about
any other field like are there any other
fields where less than 10 are women
and i love so fast that you work on
women and i mean
these it's like breast implants or tummy
tucks and it's something
personal to women and a woman is doing i
think there's a different connection
there i think when a
man does it maybe it's different but i
think no one knows a woman's better
one woman that's how i feel yeah i mean
i think i mean
i always like to say you know there's
really there's good and bag of doctors
in men and women you know what i mean
but i think that for me personally and
also the fact that
i've gotten plastic surgery done so i've
also been a patient myself
it just gives me a different perspective
but also just
communicating like i'm sure you guys
know like when a woman sits here
in your podcast you guys are just going
to mesh and have a different chemistry
or different types of conversations than
um you know you with like a guy i mean
like even little things
you know when patients come in for
breast dog that you mentioned yeah
you know like we talk about oh yeah i'm
so sick of wearing the padding or trying
to find a bra that you have to tuck in
and like
that's not something that you would
necessarily have a conversation with
about a guy
because they don't understand the
struggle there's a lot of struggle yeah
and then for vaginal
cosmetic surgery which is something that
i specialize in
just like you know the tucking in with
the bathing suits and then you're in the
you know like you're in the gym locker
room and you're kind of like feeling
uncomfortable
so those are just i think it just helps
me
relate and it makes it more comfortable
because
and i'm also open right so um
you know i think as as doctors or
physicians a lot of times
you know we struggle with being
vulnerable and open ourselves like you
know a lot of doctors feel like i have
to be a certain way to be respected
but i think when you can let that guard
down and just communicate with someone
person to person that's where the
understanding the connection
happens and i think that is what allows
me to be a really amazing doctor just
being
open and having that communication i
already feel this connection
i actually just want to hype you up
because i want everyone to know that
you're a mother
a surgeon your social media star you
have 1.2 million instagram followers you
were in a beauty pageant did you you won
it right
i did i did a lot when i was younger i
needed a fitness um your cover model for
a fitness
brand how do you do this you know it's
interesting i've gone through different
phases in my life
um so i didn't do all of them at the
same time but i think that
um i mean i did model like throughout my
teenage you know college actually i
modeled all the way through
and a lot of time like most of the time
it was to pay for school because i love
that i mean i'll be honest with you i
mean i went to harvard for college and
it was like super expensive
and i just had you know like it is when
you're a student you're just trying to
find a way so i would like you know to
teach
you know the like i was a teaching
fellow for biology and physics but then
in
you know like on my off time i would
model on the side you know
so um that to me um
was interesting because it was like it
seemed like such a clash you know back
then like oh
how can you know you're supposed to look
and be a certain way especially at
harvard like
no joke it was like though it was like
legally blonde like the
the whole l would you yeah what was the
stereotype for you then was it like
oh if you're studying to be a doctor you
can't look pretty and model like
what yeah or just or just what would
happen like actually when i was at
harvard like the first
time when i started there i lit i can't
even tell i got like hate
emails from people like we're here to
learn it's not a fashion show
just like that it was it was literally
like the movie and i'm like what but why
should it matter what you know what you
look like and vice versa
where you know i remember when i was
going for med school interviews or
residency interviews they would you know
like they would tell me oh you need to
like
wear glasses and dress down and you know
maybe change your hair because
they're not going to be able to take you
seriously and i'm like why should
what you look like on the outside
whether it's that you like to be glam or
if you have tattoos or if you just
have a different hair like they should
see you for your capability and totally
so you look amazing what do you do for
your i mean skin care you just said to
like look youthful what other things can
people do
i mean well i think that the number one
thing because i even compare my pictures
now with five years ago and i feel like
i look a lot younger but
um i'll be honest with you self-kindness
and self-compassion
just and just being good to yourself i
think are the
it's like the core of being able to like
look glowy and young and feel good and i
just can't emphasize that enough and
and it's not something i would ever have
known like my whole life
yeah um but even little things like i
mean
i get like eight to nine hours of sleep
and and this is just in the last like
two and a half years because before i
was just like i used to be
this like super type a driven
like i had a lot of personal wounds like
i had a lot to prove
yeah and so i was really just like
pushing pushing pushing myself
constantly and i mean i barely slept and
i had all these projects and i was
constantly working i mean i used to
operate
monday monday was it monday wednesday
friday saturday
wow um which meant i was working all the
time and i did like
double cases so i was there until 10 at
night i was like this crazy
person i'm working so much and i think
that but i
but i realize now after having done a
lot of personal growth it was because i
just kept hearing you can't you can't
you can in my ear and then at a certain
point i'm like wait a second i'm just
like hurting myself
you know i'm just like i'm done i'm at a
point where i don't need to prove myself
anymore and
i can now have my priorities based on my
values and create my life around that
but also the fact that i can do botox on
myself consistently that
is awesome here i'm not even joking
about the skincare the skincare
is like the foundation um
it's like the palette that you like
create everything like your whole glow
on
absolutely skincare is like a big thing
which is why i you know formulated and
founded my own skincare company just
because i feel like it's so important
i'm so passionate about it
that's amazing because especially
because you know what you're putting
into these products exactly know the
quality
exactly no i'm very
i'm always sort of i we buy so many
products like and half the stuff you
don't even use because you don't like it
we don't like it it's it's a it's fake
it breaks us out or
yeah a lot of it's just for for show and
it's not
that they don't really actually do what
they're saying you're like you're so
smart and so like on it when you say
that because i was
i felt the exact same way and people
would always ask me what to use
and then like whenever i'd go to you
know like one of those um
you know those makeup supply stores or
like a beauty store i would just
turn over the label because i want to
see like what are the ingredients
because i did a lot of scientific
research on skincare when i was
you know in pla at ucla in my plastics
training we had like this whole research
um requirement and so um i had done a
lot of research and published and spoke
about like the actual ingredients
so then for me as a consumer i'm like
you're like i just want to know what's
inside
totally and um i just couldn't i just
couldn't i didn't feel comfortable
recommending anything because i felt
like i couldn't stand behind something
100
like people are asking me my opinion i'm
just like i don't know
or you like see one thing it has like
some ingredients you like but then it
doesn't it's missing something and then
you're like kind of mixing them together
but then you don't know wait if i put
them together are they going to cancel
each other out or
maybe well i'm so excited to try your no
you will like i'm telling you i feel
like nothing you've ever
felt before because oh my gosh and
you'll appreciate it because i feel like
you have
the understanding when it comes to skin
care to like
to be able to appreciate the details
because
like even for example like hyaluronic
acid because i heard you look at the
bacteria like chloric acid
i will tell you this hyaluronic acid it
has to be a certain small particle size
to actually go
into the skin to be effective it's like
a certain kilodaltons and it's a bit and
they've shown like they actually do
they actually do studies where they have
like different sizes of the high ironic
particles and some go in and some don't
so
when i was you know working with my
manufacturer i'm like
i need to know the size of the
hyaluronic acid in kilodons and they
were just like
what this is just the hierarchy that
everyone uses i'm like i know but it's
really important
otherwise it just doesn't go in it sits
on the outside then it's like taking
like you know moisture out right and
like that one raw material took like
i mean i think five or six months for
them to find and they thought it was a
crazy person they're like
you know going back and forth they're
like no one's ever asked us that no
one's ever
like so funny and i'm like but it's
important but you hit something that
people don't notice
and that companies obviously aren't
acknowledging is that that particle size
is
seriously the significance between or
the difference between having something
that works
and doesn't work but i definitely want
to jump into your brand new show
okay doctor 90210 it's coming out
september 28th right yes
on e on e you guys i watched the first
two episodes already
how did you see
first of all you look glowing on it you
look so good and everything that you're
saying now it's like you say with your
patience and i honestly
loved watching the relationship that you
have with them it's very intimate and
personal and you can tell that they're
there like feeling insecure about this
and you really just put their minds at
ease which is like
i find that not a lot of doctors do that
are surgeons so that was really exciting
so what can we
expect from the show well i mean i this
show is
so near and dear to my heart i mean i
have actually been working on this show
for over
five years like it went through i mean
it's a long story but i mean it's a
project that i'm so
passionate about and um it was an idea
that you know
i've been brought to the network um
through
through various channels because i just
felt like there was
a need to show plastic surgery in the
way that was inspiring
brave and transformative as it really is
i mean you know the the what the
patients who
seek plastic surgery are just so
um you know they're so amazing and a lot
of them have been through so many things
in their life and they're just
looking for a physical transformation
that they can
almost use as like closure on their past
as
you know their new beginning where they
can just take off and fly
and i think that the media has just
portrayed social media oh sorry it's
portrayed plastic surgery so often as
being like very superficial or surface
or just super
entertaining yes um and which it
which i think is is great because i
think in the past
it allowed plastic surgery just to be a
part of like conversation it let it be
less taboo so it was necessary
but i think showing a deeper side really
delving into patient stories where you
feel that connection and you
understand there's such an intimacy
understanding the why is just so
relatable because it's not i always say
it's not just a show about the plastic
surgery patients or
you know about for female plastic
surgeons it really is a show like about
every person because everyone has
certain things about themselves that
maybe they feel
a little bit uncomfortable about or a
little insecure about or
even just the way that we evaluate
ourselves um
is just so relatable you know so i just
the transfer and the transformations are
unbelievable like i honestly think like
my hardest cases
ever were on the show really i was gonna
ask like seriously i'm like you guys
gonna make it easy for me
um um not it's not
nervous it's just very it was a little
bit different because
i mean i film all my surgeries for my
social media regardless so i am
used to doing and they're like step by
step
like live surgeries so i am used to you
know
being like being filmed while i'm
operating i think what was
different is just like i mean there was
definitely way more people in the room
and and my or is like literally this
like
sanctuary i mean when patients come in
like the lights go down
i play these delta wave um meditations
you set them
so relaxing um because the way that
patients
go under anesthesia and have surgery it
really greatly affects their overall
recovery and how they do so for me it's
like this
very peaceful controlled
you know it feels like they're going to
like a spa you know like those like yeah
that's
lovely and um and and so and and then
when i operate
i'm like i'm like seriously like control
freak that's like why i'm one place
where i'm just like it has to be quiet
there's no no
it's perfect everyone like no phones can
be on like i have like this whole
gigantic list of like
rules oh yeah and so um the first
surgery i
i did on the show was like literally i
can't even tell you like when you see
it it was it's like my most challenging
case ever like my patient had lost
over 200 pounds it was like the like the
most
skin i had ever had to deal with ever
actually i'm so excited because
speaking about surgeries i found out you
are like a pioneer when it comes to body
contouring and vaginal rejuvenation that
you just do an incredible job
and i've looked at all these like
reviews and i've looked at the woman
that
we were on your youtube channel yeah and
what it's called a labiaplasty surgery
yeah
so i'll let you sort of explain it
professionally
what it is but um the title of your
video was like designer vagina
and so how often do you find like these
women coming in for like
the gucci's of vaginas you know this is
probably one of the most common
surgeries that i perform
really like literally yesterday i think
i had like four labioplasty consults
what is it can you explain to people
so um so just to review the anatomy
of the vagina there's the outer labia
um outer labia majora which has like the
hair on it and then the inner
the inner labia minora and so what
labiaplasty
does is it shapes or removes the excess
labia minora so
um a lot of women have like excess
tissue that sort of sticks out
past the outer like the outer lips and
because of that
it you know like you can one sometimes
they can see it so like a lot of my
patients tell me like in clothing or
yoga clothing or legging they feel like
they see a bulge
or two just because people are so active
and like i have a lot of patients who do
spin class
yeah um they just or even like with sex
they just feel like it's
constantly pulling it gets irritated
and then like you know usually they go
on to my website and there's like i
don't know 100 plus
picture before and after pictures and
then they just see
symmetric and tucked in and you know
because everyone has a little bit of
asymmetry and
um you know and i always emphasize the
fact that everyone is normal like i have
seen
like probably more vaginas than anyone
on the planet
and like every single person is
different you know and then um which is
which is fine and like and i just tell
people that you know there's no
it's not like a need right there's never
a need to get plastics or it's just a
want thing and so some women they just
want to have it look
nice and tucked in and then it's not
rubbing or catching on things they just
feel more comfortable
do you have women because i know this is
a problem that people have brought up
before about
the porn industry and then seeing all
these like perfect
picturesque vaginas and then these men
are watching it and maybe the women feel
insecure and they're like oh my husband
probably sees this and i need that did
you ever get approached like that
you know you would i know that people
think that that's
what it would be like the motivating
factor but i
almost never hear that ever
um i think that it's really like when
women get this surgery
it's a very personal and almost a
private thing where
it's like in their everyday activities
like you know they'll be
doing like a spin class or they'll wear
something or like mostly a lot of time
in swimwear
and they just feel like they see it and
they feel you know a little bit
uncomfortable they'll have to like tuck
the lips in
what about post pregnancy because i know
when they get like varicose veins and
like that stuff happens
post-pregnancy i think sometimes i've
seen a lot of tears you know because it
rips through
but i have patients who are in like you
know like they're 18 years old and they
just just genetically
maybe one side is like five times longer
than the other okay
or they just you know like everyone
wears leggings and
like stuff like that nowadays so i think
it's just more noticeable and then just
because i've tried to
really be more open and just have it be
out there
as a subject that can be talked about
without like any embarrassment or
shame or anything like that i think that
more women are finding out about it
because
i have patients who are older and
literally they'll tell me for like the
last
10 years they've just felt so
uncomfortable and they're like googling
at night like what they can do
sometimes they've asked their ob gyn or
their primary care doctor like
and they're like oh you know why would
you want to get that fixed like they're
super judgy or i had one
like one patient like their ob gyn sent
them to a psychiatrist because they said
that like she had body dysmorphic
disorder
because she wanted to have surgery done
that's horrible that's what i'm saying
it's horrible so i'm just like
i just want it to be like a normal
conversation
where people can if they if it bothers
you there's a lot of [ __ ]
and you can feel better you know i just
don't i feel horrible for sometimes
women they always feel like they need to
hide the fact that they've
had procedures done or they want a
procedure done so right why do you think
there's such
people carry such shame and like not and
hiding the fact that they have plastic
surgery instead of just owning it
i mean it's always a very personal
reason right um and so
a lot of times things that make us feel
shame
have to do with our past experiences i
mean that's how i think so
you know on a personal level maybe
somebody shamed them for that before
or maybe you know they brought it up and
someone you know
judged them in a really harsh way and it
created a wound that you know made them
feel like it was wrong
right i mean i think that the beauty of
you know putting plastic surgery out
there on social media or even having a
tv show that really delves deeper
into the motivation for why people get
plastic surgery
will really help you know it will help
people just
be more be more at
peace and feel more you know and feel
less
judged from being able to do things for
their body that they
you know they deserve to do i mean in
theory like
i mean you know we all we all make our
own personal choices for ourselves
whether it's
hair color lash extensions you know
tattoos
piercings i mean they're just like so
many everyone expresses themselves in a
different
way with like you know i always say you
know god gives us a body
right and and so we have like you know
to to be able to
use it for what we want and also to be
able to express ourselves however we
desire
um that's why we have a physical form
right um and so
i think that it's just it hopefully will
allow
people to be able to do whatever they
want just be comfortable
in their own skin without being without
having to feel
shame because there's no reason there's
no reason
before we jump into listener um because
we asked our listeners what they would
want to know
according to like vaginal rejuvenation
and i have a question about
how much is usually a vaginal
rejuvenation and how long is the
recovery process because i'm curious
like
two different things no they're two
different things so labiaplasty is the
surgery that reshapes and sometimes i
combine it with like clitoral hood
reduction but that's a surgery
for the labia minora um that
removes excess tissue and shapes it so
the pictures that you saw on my before
and after most of them are that
vaginal rejuvenation is a totally
different thing so vaginal rejuvenation
is a non a non-surgical
procedure that uses radiofrequency
technology to
tighten the tissues and build collagen
so that is like there are two different
things so one is surgical and one is not
some a lot of times patients get both
um and you guys are super young so you
wouldn't even think about this but i'm
just telling you like as you get older
or post pregnancy there's just a lot of
changes it's like
that happen to your skin in general as
we get older we're constantly losing
collagen and elasticity
and you know you know like i mean i'm
always like i'm looking at my part i'm
trying to show you an example but like
you know so the skin changes and like it
becomes like almost like creepy
and sometimes the skin gets loose so
okay you know the
the vaginal layer just like anywhere
else on your body and so
um you know radiofrequency is used to
build
collagen and elastin and it literally
just like tightens everything
and how long is that for like how long
is the recovery process that one has no
anesthesia there's no downtime
it's like just done in the office it
takes like 45 minutes with a laser
it's not laser because laser burns okay
the vaginal rejuvenation technology
it's it's radio frequencies so it
doesn't burn the surface but what it
does is it builds collagen in the
connective tissue area and it also like
increases blood flow and sensation and
so like for a lot of women also it helps
with incontinence just anecdotally
does also help or orgasms as well
studies have shown
that um because it increases blood flow
to the clitoris and the g-spot which are
right in that
area um it has improv you know the
studies show that it improves um
increases the number and the frequency
of organelles i would do that after
pregnancy
i would do that right now a lot of girls
do i mean a lot of people do it right
now but a lot most of my patients like
they're looking at the outside and then
i'm like hey you know like as an added
bonus we treat everybody so the two
surgeries though are
the the clitoral hood that's a removable
thing and then
the the plastic but those are usually
done together because you want it to all
flow
right like you wouldn't want to have the
you know the bottom two thirds like the
labia with
like the wings yeah um be like all nice
and symmetric and tucked in and then if
you happen to have like a lot of tissue
at the top you don't want you want it to
just be balanced and have a really
beautiful curve the whole way through
what are the prices between the radio
frequency and then the surgery
um well the so the radio frequency
procedures usually
a complete like a complete treatment is
considered a set of
three okay um and i do them myself
so um i mean they're kind of i mean
they're three thousand dollars a
treatment
and then for the labioplasty with
clitoral hood reduction it kind of
varies based on the complexity
um just because some people have like
literally they'll have like
an extra piece of clitoral hood or some
people have an extra labia some people
have four labia some people like
you know so everyone's a little
different and so um it can range
anywhere from like
13 000 to like up to 20. if it's like
super extensive or there's a lot of
tears and it involves reconstruction
so it just depends but i have i mean
the way that i do the labioplasty
surgery is just a special technique that
i have developed
over time that like literally at
like two months you just you cannot even
tell it was done because i'll do vaginal
rejuvenation and you cannot even see the
scar line it is like
pristine i know who i'm going to that's
right but i just tell patients just look
at that if you just look at the before
and after photos you can see because
there's other doctors who do it but they
have a different technique kind of like
a traditional way that i had learned it
but i would look and see like like you i
think if you can tell that surgery was
done
it's better not to do anything at all
right so the way that i have
developed my technique it does take
longer
but i'm literally like i operate with
these three and a half magnifying loops
and i
i literally go back and forth and i take
like but that's great millimeters just
to get it as perfect as possible i
guarantee the women
are dying for that almost non-noticeable
treatment like they don't want to see
the difference like i would never want
to just
completely see my i mean if i've had a
baby and then also see like the changes
of it to make it prettier like i don't
want to see all the scarring but
you know that you have to be precise to
let these women feel so confident like
oh no this is no i usually end up
putting like over
200 plus sutures and it's like this i
can't even
it's it's really hard to describe and
like honestly like if i
i i would love to get a little myself i
just don't dress
and i've had like these dress where i've
had like these dreams where i'm like
able to operate on myself
and then i wake up i'm like oh it's hard
because i'm like i can't i'm like i
can't know i can't reach and i need a
driver like mirror nah it's not gonna
happen right but
um but it's just it's one of like my
signature
special surgeries that i do um and and
really it makes such a difference for
women's lives not
so they are thinking about it already
but just so they don't have to think
about it every day that's like the whole
point is just
you can just go about your life do
whatever feel comfortable in any
situation or with your partner where
you're not having to like
hide be able to tuck things in like
you're not worried it's going to get
twisted in your underwear i'm telling
you like really it makes
it makes sense it's different for the
people who choose to have it i love that
so we we asked our followers to if they
have any questions for you we pulled out
two of our favorite questions okay right
because we i think we answered so many
of them before but like these are the
two that came out most frequently one
sort of on the topic of what we're
saying right now is how painful is the
recovery for veterans she said not
really
right no so for any of my surgeries um i
have a really gentle technique and my
patients don't have any pain
even from my tummy tuck seriously
afterwards even tummy tuck surgeries
which is one of the biggest most
invasive surgeries
um my patients most of them just take
tylenol they're walking that night
um i almost can't have anyone doing nor
you know like to need to take norco or
anything i give it to them but no one
ever uses it
um even for like lipo bbl so even for
for vaginal cosmetic surgery my patients
take tylenol
it swells a lot because you know
obviously like the you know like if you
get your lips done your lips well it's
like the same thing down there like it
just swells a lot but
um for all of my surgeries the way that
i do it i'm just
really really super gentle in my
surgeries and that there's no
you know ripping like a lot of people
rush their surgeries for me
i just take my time i do it really
gentle control there's like
little to no bleeding and my patients do
amazing they like have like almost no
bruising
and i show it on purpose because i think
a lot of people are afraid to get
surgery done because of the recovery or
they think they're just gonna
you know look like look totally beat up
after yeah so i
show on my social media like one day
after tummy tuck one week after tummy
tuck and you can see
like there's no bruising patients are
like you know looking like they're
walking around you know they're not all
beat up yeah and
and i think it's it's really important
because surgery can be done
in a way that's gentle where um there's
a quick recovery i just don't like to
hurt people they're so sweet
even like with botox like i'm like
numbing and i ice and i have this like
little vibrating thing and i just don't
like to i just don't like to
hurt people so it's beautiful like
it's important to me then the second
question is
what is one plastic surgery trend that
you see up and coming
and going out of style i have to see it
coming and going away
i mean it's hard to i'll be honest with
you right now with covid if you're like
i don't really know
you know there's like all every single
plastic surgery conference is on zoom
and i'm sorry i just can't sit there on
zoom
um i mean there's like a few i mean i've
seen a bunch of different things i mean
i think that there's a lot of
there's always new non-invasive trends
like new technology
um i am always really careful about
things that are like
the new the new trend because
i'm always like let me let people
experiment for five years and then i'll
try it on myself and then i'll do it on
one of my patients you know
but i feel like i feel like a lot of the
trends
now are more about like having a more
natural look whereas
a few years ago i feel like everything
was like so exaggerated
with like big with the lips and the
butts and like people were really
wanting to just to go
super extreme yeah and i think recently
like a lot of high profile people have
been starting to like dissolve their
filler
or like try to like have more natural
shape and i feel
like that has been the thing that i see
more now because i think less and less
people are coming into the office and
like showing me these extreme pictures
that they want
and they're kind of emphasizing more
like you know they kind of want it to
look more natural
um but i guess for me just because of my
specialty and just from being so vocal
about
the vaginal cosmetic surgery like i just
feel like so many more people are
getting that done
and even in the last few months i think
because like all the production houses
have been shut like
i've had so many like you know high
profile or celebrity patients come in
asking for this surgery so i feel like
wow this is a conversation or this is
something that is becoming more open
like i think i watched two movies when i
was on quarantine and they were talking
about like
you know getting vagina surgery and i'm
like yes
and uh so i i feel like this will become
something that's just more and more
common and then also like when people
just
see what the afters look like they're
like oh yeah
well it's so amazing that you have this
new show dr 90210 coming out september
28th that you have this platform
to sort of normalize vaginal
rejuvenation normalize plastic surgery
i think it's so good you guys i'm so
excited for you all to see it
um why don't you plug all of your
socials right now okay so my instagram
my instagram
snapchat and also my tick tock is beauty
by dr cat
and for those of you who are less
squeamish and don't mind seeing more
surgical medical stuff
my instagram my medical page is
at surgeon that's pretty easy to
remember
and if you're into beauty and skin care
my skin care
instagram is um called my
md glam i highly recommend everyone
listening to go dive
into this dark hole that i went into and
just stalked the heck out of all your
people
it was so fascinating seeing you do
these procedures and honestly i'm
terrified of surgery but you made it
look so like fun i don't know why
i think we're considering now i'm like
we're coming to you
i'm getting proud of the vagina i'm so
excited i'll get the gucci she'll get
products
thank you so much for your so welcome it
was so nice meeting both of you it's so
great you look beautiful and i'm so
happy
me too bye bye
all of us here at the show thank you
thank you
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week
you